[Musique]
Marie dosée vous êtes l'une des plus
grandes pénalistes françaises une
ténorah ou une virtuose du barreau
pourtant vous ne vous dessinez pas
vraiment auprès de toi c'est presque un
excellent parcours même oui c'est un
accident parcours j'étais
plutôt vouée à quelque chose artistique
oui j'étais passionnée de musique que
j'en ai j'en ai beaucoup pratiqué
j'avais très envie d'en faire ma ma
profession et puis la vie la maladie en
l'occurrence on a décidé autrement et
quelque part je n'en finis plus
aujourd'hui de remercier la maladie de
m'avoir contrainte à bifurquer c'était
c'était merveilleux mais ce que je vis
aujourd'hui est encore plus merveilleux
votre vocation serait née au tribunal de
Nancy lors d'une plénerie d'Henri
Leclerc Henri Leclerc à l'époque je
connaissais pas mais je suis vraiment
entrée par hasard dans ce tribunal qui à
l'époque était place Stanislas cette si
jolie place et je me suis dirigée vers
la salle d'audience c'était un pur
hasard
en fait vraiment je suis faite pour ça
donc j'ai pas de mérite j'ai pas dans le
sacrifice ou dans la souffrance en tout
cas je suis vraiment heureuse là où je
suis et je sens que je suis à ma place
j'ai essayé bah parfois d'aller ailleurs
en me disant mais physiquement c'est
difficile il faut vraiment de
l'endurance mais en réalité non je suis
vraiment bien là quand au RER j'ai pas
le permis de conduire donc c'est vrai
que je vais à Fresnes à Fleury-Mérogis à
Villepinte et à l'enterre et à Bobigny
en RER depuis toujours et voilà je me
suis faite Marie 2e vous êtes quand même
un ovni dans cette profession peu ou pas
d'ego vous fréquentez plus les parloirs
que les dîners en ville vous êtes une
bagarreuse tendance pugnace et vous ne
rechignez pas à déplaire est-ce que
précisément vous avez fait ce métier
parce que vous en foutiez de plaire
ça a jamais été oui ça a jamais été une
une question dans ma vie
plaire être aimé la séduction c'est pas
du tout ce qui a pu me guider ou ce qui
a pu m'attirer j'aime d'ailleurs très
peu les gens qui cherchent à plaire j'ai
tendance à les fuir mais d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant parce que j'ai aussi
compris que on ne pouvait pas faire ce
métier parce qu'on avait envie ou besoin
d'être aimé par ce la même qu'on
défendait attention moi je me souviens
d'un de mes premiers dossiers
vous verrez maître quand je sortirai de
prison vous aurez plein de cadeaux je
vous paierai et j'ai encore la carte
postale qui est affichée sur mon cabinet
de de cette personne qui se retrouvait
en vacances dans une destination de rêve
encore merci pour tout une fois qu'il
est sorti pas besoin
ne s'arrêtent pas d'être voyou pas
toujours très honnête ou parfois ingrat
avec nous donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant j'aime défendre j'aime
défendre et je n'ai pas besoin
effectivement d'être aimé pour aimer
défendu et vous aimez défendre des
sujets controversés vous êtes en
première ligne pour le retour des
enfants de djihadistes en ou le droit à
l'oubli on vous doit d'ailleurs cet
éloge la prescription paru en 2021
comment en êtes-vous arrivé à en devenir
l'avocat de presque attitré le droit à
l'oubli est à ce point menacé qu'il fait
le défendre
oui c'est plus la prescription ça n'est
pas que le droit à l'oubli c'est aussi
un moment donné pour moi
le plus beau rempart contre l'arbitraire
la prescription c'est d'abord ça c'est
d'abord un instrument de lutte contre
l'arbitraire plus on poursuit
tardivement plus on autorise des
justiciables à déposer plein de 30 ans
45 ans 60 ans après les faits plus on
risque fort de se confronter à
l'arbitraire d'un jugement qui ne vaut
plus rien puisqu'on va condamner son
preuve donc c'est d'abord ça la
prescription elle a été conçue et elle
est née d'une volonté de lutter contre
l'arbitraire des poursuites des
poursuites à l'époque il y avait pas de
de les progrès technique on n'avait pas
d'ADN mais c'est pour ça qu'on a doublé
les délais de prescription et encore je
dis doubler dans le dans le meilleur
mais mais la réalité c'est qu'on bat
beaucoup plus loin ce que je veux dire
c'est que on a pris en considération les
techniques et tant mieux moi je ne me
suis jamais opposé au fait qu'à un
moment donné on a considéré juste et
légitime de doubler les délais de
prescription de l'action publique
c'était nécessaire alors comment
expliquer vous qu'au fil des ans la
prescription soit devenue le symbole de
l'injustice par excellence mais parce
qu'on confond justice et vengeance
parce que on place le procès à un
mauvais endroit parce qu'on fait croire
à une victime qu'elle ne pourra pas
guérir sans un procès sans une
judiciarisation de ce qu'elle a vécu ce
qui est faux ce qui est absolument faux
donc en réalité on est en train aussi de
construire une escroquerie judiciaire et
intellectuelle mais j'ai pas de
difficulté à l'assumer à le dire je
défonce certes des mises en examen des
prévenus des accusés mais je défends
aussi des parties civils et des victimes
et je sais à quel point leur asséné que
le procès a une vertu cathartique c'est
faux c'est mais que répondez-vous à
celles et ceux et ils sont nombreux qui
voient dans la prescription la négation
pure et simple des actes dénoncés et des
souffrances endurées mais je leur dis
que ils sont en train de penser non pas
la justice mais la vengeance et c'est ça
la difficulté il ne faut pas qu'on
puisse croire
que parce que celui que vous a fait
souffrir souffrira on souffrira moins
c'est pas vrai c'est encore une fois
faire dépendre son sort de celui qui
vous a fait du mal c'est aussi perpétuer
le lien c'est bizarre mais c'est comme
ça c'est à dire que l'important c'est de
de casser la chaîne entre le bourreau et
la victime c'est pas de l'entretenir en
considérant que tant qu'il est pas puni
je ne peux pas aller mieux c'est pas
vrai c'est pas ça donc il n'y a aucune
vertu de cathartique au procès si bien
sûr oui cela peut arriver ça n'est pas
son dessin ça n'est pas sa raison d'être
mais ça peut arriver mais il peut
arriver aussi et nous le savons tous
nous les pénalistes que le procès soit
le début d'une nouvelle souffrance il se
peut aussi que la justice n'épouse pas
le temps de la réparation moi j'ai connu
certaines parties civiles vous avez été
proche et vous avez suivi défendu des
victimes de viol aussi mais bien sûr je
continue en défendre au moment où je
vous en parle et j'ai connu certaines
victimes et certaines parties civiles
qui étaient répa beaucoup mieux au
moment du procès intervenu deux trois
quatre ans après l'effet et qui et bien
allait beaucoup plus mal à l'issue du
procès parce qu'elles ont dû revivre ce
qu'elles avaient pourtant résolu elles
ont dû revivre les traumatismes
recommencer vous savez la difficulté
c'est que le procès ça n'est pas le lieu
du rendez-vous non de la réconciliation
la résolution c'est pas vrai c'est pas
ça on est là pour juger un homme on
n'est pas là pour essayer de faire en
sorte que la parole de cet homme fasse
du bien à la partie civile c'est pas ça
donc l'espace judiciaire au fond n'est
pas lieu de la réparation non la justice
restaurative peut-être et j'en parle je
parle de certains de certains mécanismes
de justice restaurative et que j'ai pu
que j'ai pu mettre à l'épreuve dans ma
pensée mais aussi dans dans ce que j'ai
pu entendre de tout cela de la part de
certaines victimes et de certains
accusés je sous-entendais par justice
restaurative c'est par exemple faire
rencontrer des victimes avec des
personnes condamnées
pour des infractions similaires pas les
victimes des personnes condamnées mais
des victimes et des personnes condamnées
et puis entouré par des psychologues des
éducateurs des accompagnateurs des
professionnels il s'écoutent
il se raconte leur histoire la victime
histoire de son traumatisme et le
condamné l'histoire de son passage à
l'acte et moi j'ai vu à quel point ça
pouvait faire avancer la personne j'ai
entendu par exemple des victimes dire
mais j'ai compris grâce à ces ateliers
de justice restaurative que c'est pas à
moi qu'il en voulait ça aurait pu être
quelqu'un d'autre c'est tombé
il y a beaucoup de choses comme ça mais
le lieu du procès ça ne peut pas être le
lieu de la réparation c'est un temps
parfois avant le procès parfois après le
procès mais donc au fond ce que vous
dites c'est qu'il y a un énorme
malentendu sur le rôle même de la
justice oui mais ça on peut pas à la
fois
instrumentaliser le judiciaire comme on
le fait politiquement depuis des
décennies et en même temps demander aux
citoyens aux justiciables de comprendre
ce qu'est exactement un procès dire on
est en train de sombrer dans un
populisme pénal nous l'avons écrit nous
le mais nous le ressentons chaque jour
un peu plus
la justice c'est aujourd'hui transformée
en immense faits divers on l'enseigne
pas à l'école et en même temps on en
veut toujours plus c'est ça qui
extraordinaire c'est ce qu'on veut
toujours plus de justice et en même
temps on ne cesse de dire qu'on n'est
jamais satisfait des jugements donc il y
a quelque chose qui prouve que la
justice est d'abord malade
d'elle-même d'elle-même mais surtout du
fait qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'elle est de
notre ignorance
l'injustice le procès c'est juger un
homme se prononcer sur sa culpabilité et
se prononcer ensuite sur la peine
d'accord et la souffrance de la victime
ce n'est pas la preuve de la réalité
d'une infraction c'est terrible mais
c'est comme ça et heureusement on est
dans un état de droit
mais je sais à quel point aujourd'hui
c'est inaudible moi j'ai parfois des des
réflexions qui sont de cette de cet
ordre là mais puisqu'il souffre et
puisqu'elle souffre ça ne prouve pas
qu'il a commis l'acte
vous rendez compte aujourd'hui la
souffrance est une preuve mais non
vous citez Aristote en exergue de votre
livre la mémoire ne sert pas seulement à
se souvenir elle sert aussi à oublier en
quoi l'oubli est-il nécessaire
absolument même indispensable à une
démocratie digne de ce nom
donc il y a plusieurs formes d'oubli je
pense que
il faut réussir à ranger quelque part
ce qu'on a vécu et notamment nos plus
grands traumatismes réussir à les ronger
quelque part pour qu'il se réveille le
moins possible oubliez ça n'existe pas
c'est pas possible une victime de viol
une jeune enfant de 10 ans qui a vu ses
parents mourir sous ses yeux n'oublie
pas mais l'important c'est qu'elle
puisse ranger cela quelque part et ça ça
se construit tout simplement je pense
que c'est essentiel j'ai beaucoup de mal
avec ce que j'appelle l'identité
victimaire vous comprenez puisque le
statut de la victime a beaucoup évolué
ces dernières années dans la société
bien sûr dans très longtemps les parties
civils les plaignantes donc les victimes
après déclaration de culpabilité était
les parents pauvres de la procédure
pénale elle n'avait aucun droit elle
n'avait pas accès au dossier et on
estimait quelque part qu'elle n'avait
pas grand chose à faire dans une
procédure petit à petit elles ont acquis
et je ne critique pas cela les mêmes
droits que les mises en examen elles
peuvent faire devant un juge
d'instruction demander des
confrontations demander des contrats
d'expertise interjeter appel des
ordonnances de renvoi des ordonnances de
mise en accusation elles l'établissement
voilà elles sont parties au procès elles
sont pleinement parties au procès et je
n'ai aucune difficulté là-dessus mais
maintenant il ne faut pas qu'elle le
prenne en otages et parfois on ressent
ça et moi je ça ne me pose pas seulement
une difficulté par rapport à ce que doit
être ce que doit rester un procès ça me
pose aussi une difficulté par rapport à
elle par rapport à elle parce qu'on le
font dépendre leur reconstruction de
l'issue d'un procès faut pas qu'elle
fasse ça il faut pas qu'elle fasse la
reconstruction elle est nécessairement
intime elle relève de l'ordre de
l'intime et non pas de l'espace
souvenir peut-être tyrannique et
fabriqué des victimes à jamais en quoi
l'abus de souvenirs peut-il être
préjudiciable
je crois qu'il ne faut pas laisser
entendre à ceux qui ont vécu quelque
chose de traumatique qu'elle ne s'en
sortiront jamais et quels sont
nécessairement dépendantes de se
souvenir traumatique et j'ai parfois
l'impression que certaines techniques de
psychothérapie ou que certains ou
certaines psychologues vont dans ce sens
là c'est à dire ne cesse de contraindre
ou d'inviter la personne à ressasser
encore et toujours en expliquant que la
libération
doit dépendre de ceci ou de cela et en
réalité on ferme la personne dans ce
qu'elle a vécu dans son statut victime
ouais vous invoquez d'ailleurs Samantha
gamer victime à 13 ans d'une relation
sexuelle que romane Polanski lui aurait
imposé en 1977 et qui implore depuis 40
ans on cesse de la réduire à cette
histoire qu'il affiche au fond dans son
statut de victime exactement c'est à
dire qu'on en fait les statues des
identités victimaires et des statues
elle n'existe que parce qu'elles sont
victimes mais c'est très très dangereux
d'abord parce que pour certaines
personnes à un moment donné qui vont
trouver de l'écoute qui vont trouver en
fin du confort qui vont dans leur vie
n'avoir jamais été autant aimé que
depuis qu'elles sont victimes
elles vont avoir du mal à se sortir de
ce statut là et je peux vous assurer
qu'on est en train de glisser sur un
terrain qui à mon avis me semble encore
plus dangereux pour elle que pour la
société tout entière d'ailleurs vous ne
croyez pas du tout à l'amnésie
traumatique qui est devenu d'ailleurs
l'étendard des pros imprescriptibilité
je ne crois pas du tout en ce qu'on en a
fait je pense que l'amnésie traumatique
en soi elle existe mais la difficulté
c'est son instrumentalisation
tout n'est pas amnésie traumatique et
c'est ça la difficulté c'est que lorsque
je lis certains articles et notamment
certains travaux dont c'est devenu un
concept fortune
pour tout mais n'importe quel souvenir
devient nécessairement
traumatique ou une amnésie traumatique
enfin c'est il y a quelque chose encore
de la construction là qui m'apparaît moi
extrêmement dangereux mais pas mais pas
que moi je cite des des psychiatres des
qui remettent en cause d'ailleurs c'est
complètement et qui remettent ce qui
remettent ce concept et puis surtout qui
critiquent son instrumentalisation et
qui explique à quel point cela peut
paraître extrêmement dangereux de plus
en plus d'affaires sont instruites dans
les médias en prenant l'opinion à témoin
on pense bien sûr à DSK Roman Polanski
Gabriel mazenev Denis Baupin Olivier
Duhamel Richard Berry encore pépère on
va pas tous les citer or la première
victime de ces affaires-là dites-vous
c'est la présomption d'innocence l'un
des principes fondamentaux de nos droits
mais elles veulent en éclat à le dire
autrement alors c'est tout on y arrivera
pas si dès l'instant où on considère que
la justice ne peut plus être saisie
parce que les faits sont prescrits et
bien ça n'empêche pas les plaignants qui
ne peuvent plus l'être d'être victimes
devant des caméras de télévision s'en
est terminée en même temps le parquet ne
vous aide pas il ouvre des enquêtes
préliminaires y compris sur des faits
prescrits ce serait une mission de
service public mais je vais vous révéler
quelque chose parce qu'on en parle
jamais c'est pire que ça et je l'ai pas
écrit dans mon livre parce que cette
circulaire de Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti a été prise quelques mois
après la partie de mon livre non
seulement le procureur ouvre des
enquêtes préliminaires sur des faits
prescrits mais lorsqu'il classe ensuite
pour fait prescrit cela veut dire qu'il
considère que les faits sont caractérise
s'ensuit en disant les faits ne sont pas
caractérisés c'est que les faits ne sont
pas caractérisés donc écoutez-moi bien
parce que c'est dingue le seul crime
dont on ne pourra jamais prouver
innocence et le crime prescrit le seul
délit dont on ne pourra jamais prouver
l'innocence devant une juridiction
devant des jugements indépendants devant
un tribunal c'est le délit prescrit
c'est complètement dingue aujourd'hui
quand on classe s'ensuit une enquête
pour des faits prescrits ça veut dire
que les faits sont construits alors
justement
ces cas-là aurait au moins l'avantage
leur permettre d'avoir un procès digne
de ce nom et d'entendre toutes les
parties non mais parce que 40 ou 50 ans
après que voulez-vous faire d'une
déclaration d'une jeune femme qui dit
mon père m'a violé ou d'un père qui dit
c'est pas vrai je l'ai pas violé 40 ou
50 ans après moi je veux bien qu'on
qu'on
crée des des audiences pour que tout le
monde aille mieux et puis que pour que
tout le monde sorte sa propre vérité et
puis qu'à la fin on on peut pas décider
parce qu'il y a pas des éléments mais
mais bon je vais pas dire que vous
mentez madame mais vous comprenez je
peux pas non plus le condamner ou alors
sa parole suffit c'est plus du doigt
alors comment réparer et trouver le
juste équilibre entre réparation d'une
infraction étant l'oublie comment
comment on faut prendre en charge les
plaignantes qui se sont lésées par la
justice elles ont un profond sentiment
d'injustice c'est ça qui ont un profond
sentiment d'injustice sont pour
l'instant victime entre guillemets de
l'ancien loi mais on nous a expliqué
qu'il fallait changer les textes parce
que Vanessa aspringora ne pouvait pas
déposer plainte ou parce que le frère de
Madame couchter ne pouvait pas déposer
plainte mais en réalité c'est faux ça
c'est faux on nous a pondu des
propositions de loi en nous expliquant
que c'était parfaitement injuste que ces
fans là ne peuvent pas déposer plainte
et que donc il fallait rallonger les
délais de prescription mais il était
déjà c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on
peut déposer plein de jusqu'à ses 48 ans
le frère de Madame Kouchner ou madame
springora avait moins de 48 ans quand
elle révèle les faits donc ça aurait pu
porter plainte sous sous l'égide sous
l'application de la loi nouvelle oui
mais la loi elle est pas rétroactive
c'est tout donc on est en train
d'allonger des délais de prescription en
disant c'est scandaleux regardez c'est
pauvres victimes les faits sont
prescrits mais ils ne le sauront plus
jamais donc en réalité ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui ce sont d'affaires que l'on
considère comme un juste parce que
prescrite alors que avec les nouvelles
lois elle ne le serait pas mais vous
rendez compte qu'aujourd'hui il y a de
plus en plus de victimes d'infractions
sexuelles d'ailleurs qui ne vont pas au
commissariat qui prennent le pignon à
témoin parce qu'elle considère que la
justice est défaillante oui mais est-ce
que vous vous rendez compte surtout
qu'est-ce que ça donne l'opinion
publique à témoin parce que la justice
est défaillante c'est être dans la
sphère de la vengeance et rien d'autre
regardez
la justice et la vengeance divine
poursuivant le crime est-ce que ça vous
inspire
j'ai le sentiment que la vengeance
aujourd'hui fait partie de la justice et
qu'on arrive plus à les dissocier
un peu comme ce tableau ou difficilement
on n'arrive plus à dissocier et c'est
très compliqué de l'expliquer mais tant
qu'on ait du CRAPA les gens à la justice
on y arrivera pas vous rendez compte
qu'on est dans un pays quand même moi je
reçois des des stagiaires de troisième
et je les emmène en comparaison
immédiate pendant une semaine
ils ne savent pas ce que c'est que la
justice les prévenus quand ils se
laissent devant un tribunal disent
bonjour Votre Honneur parce qu'ils
regardent des feuilletons américains
toute la journée mais le concept l'idée
de justice
on y arrive plus moi je lorsque par
exemple j'obtiens la relax
[Musique]
d'un justiciable la partie civile répond
ça veut pas dire que qu'il innocent
c'est terminé la vérité judiciaire c'est
une vérité parmi les autres dans
l'absolu c'est vrai mais qu'est-ce qu'on
va devenir avec ça si la vérité
judiciaire ne vaut pas plus que la
vérité d'une pénombre qui dit bah oui
mais la justice se trompe et moi je dis
qu'il est quand même coupable
est-ce que est-ce qu'on se rend compte
de du glissement du glissement vers
l'arbitraire et puis vers le fait que
finalement chacun a ses vérité et à
partir de là effectivement il y a plus
de présomption innocence glissement à
tel point qu'on entend de plus en plus
de gens réclamés le retour de la peine
de mort oui alors n'oublions pas que la
peine de mort a été abolie alors que la
majorité des Français était contre
l'abolition de la peine de mort d'accord
c'est une mort sociale aucune difficulté
là-dessus moi et en plus quelque chose
d'infantilisant qui m'agace j'avais pris
position à l'époque sur Quentin mais
mais pas parce que je trouve que le
pauvre monsieur Quentin c'est pas ça
c'est juste que de voir des des jeunes
femmes ou des jeunes hommes balancés de
la peinture rouge sur des gens qui
viennent écouter Bertrand Cantat en
concert effectivement vous avez des prix
fait des causes pour battre en Quantin
dans une tribune publiée dans le journal
Le Monde
vous vous indignez je cite qu'il soit
condamné au silence par respect pour la
douleur des victimes chacune de ces
apparitions est en vécu comme une
indécente provocation écrivez-vous ce
qui de fait le condamne au silence et
elle mord sociale comment sortir de
cette spirale infernale je pense qu'il
faut des prises opposition courageuses
et notamment je pense à ce directeur de
de théâtre je crois que c'est moi watch
je suis pas certaine que ce soit lui
mais en tout cas ce directeur de théâtre
qui a refusé de et bien de l'écarter de
la programmation en disant d'abord
réfugiés en disant je sais à peu près ce
que c'est qu'être victime merci et
surtout en disant il a purgé sa peine et
je travaille avec lui si je veux
travailler avec lui je crois que c'est
cela aussi et moi c'est pas l'avocate
qui a un moment donné s'inding c'est
aussi la citoyenne je vais voir qui je
veux
comme acteur comme musicien on n'a pas à
m'imposer quelque chose lui égard au
passé d'un artiste je suis désolé mais
c'est comme ça et je pense qu'il faut
tous aussi qu'on fasse preuve d'un
certain courage pour ne pas se laisser
emporté par une vague qui est
extrêmement dangereuse vous citez
d'ailleurs François Mauriac la vengeance
déguisée en justice et notre plus
affreuse grimace oui tout à fait c'est
exactement ça et au fond la justice est
transformée en Vendetta elle est en
train de se transformer en Vendetta dès
l'instant où on considère parce que
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire et moi
je le je le mets à l'épreuve dans mon
quotidien de pénaliste
soit la justice va dans le sens de ce
que veut le justiciere et il lui donne
légitimité une sorte de légitimité c'est
ce qu'on appelle le populisme pénal soit
elle ne va pas dans son sens c'est à
dire que la personne est relaxée alors
que j'ai déposé plein de contre lui et
donc et donc elle ne vaut rien et ce
n'est pas parce qu'elle leur accès qu'il
est innocent c'est même pire il est
doublement coupable d'avoir comme il est
fait que j'ai dénoncé et d'avoir et en
plus d'avoir été et d'avoir été relaxé
donc en réalité la justice est une arme
parmi d'autres mais mais c'est ça qui
est extrêmement dangereux vous dénonciez
une circulaire du mise à justice avec
Dupond-Moretti mais j'imagine que vous
êtes d'accord pour dire avec lui que ce
n'est pas au tribunal que l'on fait son
deuil mais au cimetière ah oui mais ça
il a dit quand il était avocat la
difficulté c'est que devenu garde des
sceaux il il met en exergue le contraire
de ce qu'il a pu assainer ça c'est
dommage mais c'est effectivement ce
qu'il disait
Marie de on peut définitivement dire que
vous êtes habité par l'esprit de la loi
n'est-ce pas oui l'esprit de la loi est
j'ai très peur de cette inflation
législative j'ai très peur de cette
réforme de loi tant vous savez j'ai l'un
de mes premiers textes que j'avais écrit
avec François Scotta ça s'appelait
populisme et c'était déjà la peur
de ce qui est en train d'arriver on va
entendre on a vraiment transformé la
justice pénale qui est ce qui devrait
nous aider à vivre ensemble en
populisme vraiment on appelle à la haine
on appelle à la vengeance vous savez
quand j'étais jeune je pensais que
j'allais beaucoup militer quand j'étais
jeune avocat
j'étais avec certains avocats très
militants je pensais que j'allais
militer dans les associations etc
aujourd'hui je me rends compte que je
médite à la barre que certains
magistrats font de la résistance que moi
avocat je fais de la résistance
simplement en plaidant en exerçant mon
métier et en remettant ma robe
ce qui est merveilleux mais ce qui est
aussi extrêmement inquiétant voilà la
lutte contre les présomption d'innocence
elle est aujourd'hui vu comme une
insulte aux victimes c'est terrible
c'est terrible d'en être arrivé là et
c'est un courant contre lequel nous
sommes beaucoup à nous battre
malheureusement
non pas en vain mais presque et ce que
j'aurais juste envie de dire non pas
au Garde des sommets ce que j'aurais
envie de dire aux politiques quel qu'il
soit c'est d'arrêter d'arrêter
d'instrumentaliser la justice et de
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse travailler
sereinement parce que c'est uniquement
comme ça que les justiciables auront
confiance en institution et on doit
retrouver confiance en institution sans
cela on la consomme et avoir un rapport
de consommateur avec la justice c'est
nécessairement la perdre
merci c'est moi qui vous remercie